Quiero hacerles esta pregunta
para votar con clicker.
¡Ay, no! Esto dice que la
votación está cerrada.
Ahora la votación está abierta.
¿Te comprometiste a apagar el
Internet por completo?
Pulsa 1.
¿Te comprometiste a restringir el
Internet de alguna forma?
Es decir, lo tienes encendido, pero
prometiste no usar Facebook,
no jugar Angry Birds, no
hacer compras en línea
ni cualquier otra cosa indulgente
que hagas en Internet.
Si ese es tu caso, pulsa 2.
¿No pusiste ninguna restricción a tu
uso de Internet en la clase,
pero tienes una computadora?
En ese caso, pulsa 3.
¿Esto no aplica para ti
porque normalmente usas un lápiz
y un papel en la clase?
Ok. Se suponía que el temporizador
tenía que estar marcando la
cuenta regresiva,
pero no, ahora tengo que
parlotear durante 28 segundos.
Entonces...
Leí sus trabajos de mi
sección y me parece,
aunque no sé si leí una
muestra al azar,
que aproximadamente 2/3 de ustedes
se comprometieron a apagar el Internet
y aproximadamente 1/4 se
comprometieron a alguna
restricción
y un porcentaje muy bajo
no se comprometió
a ninguna restricción del Internet.
Ok. Deberíamos ver en un segundo
que nuestra dispositiva...
¡Sí! Ok.
El 43% de los alumnos en este salón,
hizo un precompromiso en
forma de promesa.
Se volvió un precompromiso
porque lo escribieron.
Solo pensarlo no lo hacía
un precompromiso.
En un momento en que se
sentían tranquilos,
calmados y razonables, actuaron
y tomaron la decisión
de comprometerse con ustedes
mismos en el futuro.
El 16%
no cortó por completo el Internet,
pero intentó hacer alguna
restricción intermedia.
Mi siguiente pregunta es si se han
desviado de su compromiso.
20 segundos.
1. Ni siquiera un poquito.
Ni una sola vez.
2. Solamente una o dos veces.
3. Bueno, algunas veces, pero
lo estoy intentando.
4. Sí. He estado jugando
Sparkle HD Lite en mi iPad
toda la clase.
Veamos cómo salen los resultados.
Ok. Deberíamos obtener...
eso no salió automáticamente.
Ajá. Entonces, 56% de ustedes...
¡Excelente!
56% de ustedes no se han
desviado ni un poquito.
Noten que la mitad de ustedes
no han podido continuar
con el compromiso que hicieron y al que
consideraban una obligación,
aunque habían interiorizado
en sus consciencias
la idea de que habían
hecho un compromiso.
Resulta que para muchas personas,
hacer un compromiso mental
no es suficiente
para mantenerse en la categoría de
"ni siquiera un poquito".
Para los que están en el 25%,
el 8% o incluso el 11%
puede ser útil
poner alguna especie de
restricción externa.
El New York Times sacó un
artículo la semana pasada
sobre "condones para teléfonos",
cuyo eslogan es "ciérralo,
bloquéalo y guárdalo".
La idea es poner el teléfono
en una bolsita con cierre
para que cuando conduzcan no
tengan acceso a él.
Un alumno de esta clase, me
envío por correo un enlace,
que está disponible en
esta diapositiva,
para un programa que es como un
condón para computadora,
un "ciérralo, bloquéalo y
guárdalo" para el acceso a Internet.
Apaga el acceso a Internet
durante un tiempo determinado.
Para quienes sientan que necesitan una
especie de refuerzo externo,
pero no están preparados para usar
el bloqueo del Internet,
pensé en darles algo que les ayude a
continuar con su compromiso
usando 2 cosas que
aprendimos la semana pasada.
La primera es que cuando
tenemos unos ojos enfrente
sentimos la mirada del
mundo sobre nosotros.
La segunda es que cuando hay una
especie de refuerzo social
de los compañeros es más fácil
continuar con un plan.
No solo porque me sobraron del bar
mitzvah de mi hijo mayor,
pero tengo etiquetas de caritas
felices que voy a repartirles.
Si quieren, pueden poner una
etiqueta roja o naranja
en la esquina de sus computadoras
si se comprometieron a no usar el
Internet durante la clase.
Les servirá como recordatorio y para
mostrarlo a sus compañeros.
Pueden usar una etiqueta verde o azul
si se comprometieron a un acceso
restringido durante la clase.
Pásenlas, hay 720 etiquetas, así
que no se van a acabar.
Pueden distribuirlas,
simplemente tomen unas cuantas
y váyanlas pasando.
Péguenlas o no.
No nos viene mal.
Estaban en mi escritorio desde el bar
mitzvah, que fue en octubre
y pensé que con esto podría explicar
4 cosas a la vez en la clase.
De hecho, son 5 por el tema de
la autorregulación,
porque es la pregunta
fundamental que estamos
abordando
en el contexto del material
que leímos para hoy.
Les ofrezco una disculpa
porque la clase de hoy,
en gran parte sigue el eslogan de
"hombre muerto los martes".
Voy a repasar, con un poco de detalle,
algunos argumentos de
Platón y después,
algunos argumentos de Aristóteles.
Espero que así,
tengan un marco de
referencia que les permita,
cuando vuelvan a las lecturas
o al escribir sus ensayos,
sentir que esos textos se han
vuelto comprensibles.
Como recordarán, Platón
sugiere que el alma
puede entenderse como
dividida en 3 partes.
Tenemos una parte racional,
que Platón representa a
veces como un ser humano
y a veces como un auriga.
Tenemos una parte animada,
que Platón representa a veces
como un caballo obediente
y a veces como un león.
Además, tenemos una parte apetitiva
que Platón representa a veces
como un caballo salvaje
y a veces como una bestia
con muchas cabezas.
Platón sugiere que cierta
parte de nuestra felicidad
depende de que alineemos estas 3 partes.
Escribe: "Uno es justo, cuando impide
que las partes dentro de sí
se enreden unas con otras.
Si controla bien lo que es suyo, se
domina, se pone en orden
y armoniza las 3 partes de uno mismo
como 3 notas restrictivas
en una escala musical.
Y se impide actuar de muchas formas".
Impedir ser arrastrados como
ustedes en 2 direcciones:
en la dirección de apagar el Internet
y en la dirección de
entrar al Facebook.
Arrastrados en la dirección de ir a la
biblioteca y hacer sus tareas,
y arrastrados en la dirección de
pasar el tiempo en sus cuartos
hablando con sus compañeros.
"Se impide actuar de muchas
formas", impide ser arrastrado
en la dirección de lo que
dicta la razón
y en la dirección de lo que dictan
el espíritu y el apetito,
"volverse solo uno,
moderado y armonioso".
El ideal platónico del alma bien
ordenada es un alma regulada
por la razón en la que el
espíritu y el apetito
están sujetos a las
órdenes de la razón.
Ahora quiero darles en 30
segundos, bueno en 5 minutos,
un resumen de los argumentos de
La República de Platón,
en los Libros II, III, IV y IX.
¿De acuerdo? La historia dice así:
Platón intenta decirnos
cómo es el alma humana.
Y en honor al clima, vamos a
representar al ser humano así.
Platón dice que el alma humana
está dividida en 3 partes.
Tiene una parte racional, una
parte animada o con espíritu
y una parte apetitiva, llena de apetito.
Pueden ver el ser humano, el león y
la bestia de muchas cabezas
en esta famosa imagen de Platón.
Para comprender lo que es
bueno para el ser humano,
Sócrates recomienda, al final de
la discusión del Libro II,
que leímos para la clase pasada,
que la mejor manera de
entender lo que es bueno
para el ser humano dividido en 3 es
pensar en qué sería bueno
para una ciudad estructurada
de la misma forma.
¿Qué estructuras sociales nos
pueden ayudar a entender cosas
sobre las estructuras internas
de los seres humanos?
Propone la famosa analogía
de la ciudad estado,
donde la parte del alma que
corresponde al apetito
está representada por los
ciudadanos, a los que llama obreros,
las personas que hacen el
trabajo diario en la ciudad,
que obtienen júbilo y placer
en los placeres del
cuerpo y del apetito.
Hay soldados, que defienden la ciudad,
sirven como defensores en
el contexto militar
y están motivados por el honor.
Hay, además, filósofos o guardianes,
que viven la vida de la mente.
Y verán quién termina en la
cima en esta historia.
La idea es que para comprender las 4
virtudes griegas cardinales
en el contexto individual,
nos servirá pensar
dónde se pueden encontrar esas
virtudes en una ciudad.
Después, podremos representar
lo que hayamos aprendido
al observar el problema a gran escala
en el contexto de la sociedad.
Podremos representarlo en el
problema visto a pequeña escala,
a escala individual.
Sócrates plantea que hay 4
virtudes cardinales,
ustedes ya lo saben por las lecturas.
La primera es la sabiduría.
Y la sabiduría de la
ciudad y del individuo
se encuentra en su parte racional.
Ok. Esto debería... Sí...
Está el valor.
El valor de la ciudad o de un individuo
se encuentra en sus partes
animadas o con espíritu.
Están bailando.
Y hay 2 virtudes, con una
distinción importante
en algunos contextos, pero
no en este caso,
me refiero a la templanza y la justicia.
La teoría es que igual que una
ciudad tiene templanza y justicia
cuando las relaciones entre las personas
que la habitan son apropiadas,
un individuo tiene templanza y justicia
cuando las relaciones entre sus partes
son correctas y apropiadas.
Es decir, la templanza y la
justicia implican
cierto tipo de armonía
entre las partes.
Esa es la imagen platónica.
Y es la respuesta de Platón,
en voz de Sócrates,
al reto que Glaucón nos hizo
a mitad del Libro II.
Recuerden que vimos, al
inicio del Libro II,
una distinción triple entre los bienes.
Vimos que había cosas que tienen
valor intrínsecamente,
por ellas mismas.
Cosas que tienen valor
instrumentalmente,
por los bienes que proporcionan
más allá de sí mismas.
Esas son cosas como el dinero, que no
tienen un valor intrínseco,
pero tienen un valor instrumental.
Y hay cosas que son valiosas
tanto intrínsecamente
como instrumentalmente.
Recuerden el argumento de
Glaucón, primero,
su afirmación de que al
hablar de justicia
demandamos sus beneficios en
términos de los bienes
que proporciona en reputación.
Segundo, en su relato del
anillo de Giges,
en el que argumenta que si
pudiéramos salir librados
de nuestros actos injustos,
deberíamos ser injustos.
Y tercero, en el relato de las estatuas
pulidas, o la historia invertida,
por si no se convencieron con
la historia de Giges,
seguramente si la justicia
produjera una mala reputación
y la injusticia una buena,
actuarían de forma injusta.
Esos son los 3 argumentos de Glaucón
a favor de que la justicia solo
tiene un valor instrumental.
En su imagen, la justicia solo
tiene valor para nosotros
de la misma forma que el dinero.
Puede ayudarnos a comprar cosas
que tienen valor
intrínseco en sí mismas.
Por el contrario, el
argumento de Sócrates,
es que la justicia tiene
ambas características.
No hay duda de que tiene
utilidad instrumental;
no niega los argumentos de
Glaucón ni de Adimanto
de que ser percibido como justo
nos puede ser útil.
Además,
argumenta que hay cierto valor
intrínseco asociado
con tener el alma propia
estructurada igual que el alma
justa.
Quiero señalar, para ser justos
con Glaucón y Adimanto,
que hay un poco de trampa aquí.
Glaucón y Adimanto están trabajando
con una noción poco
teorizada de la justicia.
La imagen que tienen es que la
justicia actúa más o menos
en conformidad con las reglas que
la sociedad nos impone
para ser considerados meritorios,
hablando en términos generales.
Ser justo es hacer más o menos
lo que las leyes dicen
que debemos hacer.
Por el contrario, Sócrates continúa
y nos ofrece una explicación más
sofisticada de la justicia.
Pero si esas 2 caracterizaciones
son lo que los filósofos llaman
equivalentes por extensión,
entonces Sócrates no está
haciendo trampa.
Ser equivalente en extensión
consiste en elegir un mismo
conjunto de acciones en el mundo.
Sócrates afirma que es una ley
que una persona deba ser
honesta y no matar a otros.
Asimismo, una persona con un
alma estructurada
según lo que él define como "justa"
no debe robar ni matar gente.
Es una norma de la justicia
que las personas tengamos
devoción hacia nuestros padres.
Una norma de la justicia en el
sentido convencional.
También, dice Sócrates,
es una norma de la justicia en el
sentido que él ha caracterizado
que tendremos devoción
hacia nuestros padres.
Y así sucesivamente.
El panorama es que
la noción de justicia más completa
que Sócrates nos ha dado,
coincide lo suficiente con la noción
de justicia en la que Glaucón
y Adimanto están interesados, y
esto hace que no haya trampa.
Esto permite a Sócrates
hacer 2 argumentos
a favor del valor
intrínseco de la justicia.
El primero está al final del Libro IV,
donde argumenta que la justicia
es un tipo de salud.
Más o menos, la justicia es al alma,
como la salud es al cuerpo.
Un cuerpo sano es aquel en el
que sus partes hacen
lo que deberían hacer.
Tu cuerpo está sano
si tu corazón bombea sangre
al ritmo adecuado
para que tu cerebro reciba la
cantidad de oxígeno necesaria
y las puntas de tus dedos reciban
la sangre necesaria, etc.
Al igual que la salud tiene
valor intrínseco
e instrumental en nuestro cuerpo,
también la justicia, que es
la salud del alma,
tiene valor intrínseco e
instrumental para nosotros
como elemento espiritual
añadido a los seres físicos.
Aquí el término espiritual se usa
en un sentido muy modesto.
Ese es el primer argumento.
El primer argumento
es que existe un buen camino para
que la gente funcione.
Vamos a volver a esto
en el contexto de nuestra
discusión de Aristóteles.
Hay una forma en la que se supone
que funciona el cuerpo.
Se espera que el corazón haga
esto, los pulmones esto,
las rodillas esto, los
oídos aquello, etc.
Y tenemos una imagen de lo
que es la salud.
También, dice Platón,
pensando en el proyecto sobre la
analogía de la ciudad estado,
esto muestra lo que necesita un
alma para estar sana
y resulta que la salud del
alma se dispone
según los mandatos de la justicia.
Ese es el primer argumento que ofrece.
Es un argumento a través de algo
que Glaucón y Adimanto
han admitido que tiene utilidad
intrínseca e instrumental
y una afirmación de que una vez que
entiendan lo que es la justicia,
pueden ver la analogía directa
entre el alma y la justicia,
y el cuerpo y la salud.
El segundo par de argumentos
aparece en el Libro IX
y se refiere al tema de la felicidad.
El primer argumento lo volveremos a ver
cuando leamos a John Stuart Mill
al comienzo de nuestra
sección de utilitarismo.
Es un argumento que dice así:
La persona que ha desarrollado la
capacidad de autorregulación,
la autogobernancia, a lo
largo del camino,
debido al tipo de seres que somos,
también ha experimentado todos los
otros tipos de placeres.
De cierta manera, esto se parece
a la versión freudiana.
Comenzamos como un manojo de deseos,
tomamos lo que queremos sin
tomar en consideración
las consecuencias a largo
plazo para nosotros.
Y con el paso del tiempo, tomamos
ese manojo de necesidades
sin control y le ponemos cierto orden.
Primero lo controlamos
mediante elogios y culpa,
casi sin usar nuestra parte de honor,
después lo regulamos mediante la
reflexión y el autoentendimiento.
La persona que ha llevado su
alma a un estado armonioso
está en una excelente
posición subjetivamente,
porque ha experimentado
todos los placeres
que una persona sin
autorregulación ha vivido
y además ha experimentado
el tipo de placeres
que solo están disponibles si
tenemos el alma bien ordenada.
Todos hemos experimentado el placer
de entrar a Facebook y de jugar Tetris.
Pero solo algunos hemos
experimentado el placer
de apagar nuestro Internet durante
la clase, dejarlo apagado
y escuchar lo que dice
nuestra profesora.
Quienes hemos tenido el enorme
placer de hacer lo segundo,
dice Platón, hemos
reconocido que ese placer
es un placer más grande que el
placer de jugar Angry Birds.
Dejo que quienes han
experimentado ambos placeres
evalúen ese argumento.
Ese es el primer argumento que
hace en el Libro IX.
El segundo argumento es muy interesante
y para entenderlo bien es
necesario que explique
la alegoría de la cueva, pero
no lo voy a hacer ahora.
Basta con decir que es
parte de La República
y parte de la filosofía de
Platón en general,
que el tipo de placeres terrenales
que experimentamos al interactuar
con objetos son, de hecho,
un cierto tipo de placer irreal.
No están interactuando con
aquello que es más real.
Lo más real, dice Platón, no son las
aproximaciones de círculos
que nos encontramos cuando
usamos el PowerPoint
para hacer un hombre de nieve
en una dispositiva.
Lo más real, son los ideales
matemáticos de los círculos.
La verdadera naturaleza de la
sabiduría, no es la sabiduría
que encontramos en las
personas que nos rodean,
aunque eso es maravilloso, sino
la forma de sabiduría
de la que todos estos ejemplos son
simplemente imitaciones.
Lo mismo pasa con todos los
otros placeres que tenemos.
Existen los placeres terrenales
y el dominio de cosas con
las que interactuamos
que se encuentra más allá
del reino terrenal.
He pasado mucho tiempo viendo
películas para niños
porque tengo 2 hijos.
Entre las películas que he
visto recientemente
con mi hijo menor está Narnia.
Y entre las películas que he
visto recientemente
con mi hijo mayor está El
Origen (Inception).
También hemos visto Matrix
y The Truman Show.
Todas estas películas señalan
lo que decía Platón.
La táctica en todas ellas
es que la realidad que ustedes
consideran auténtica y profunda,
como este reino terrenal, en
el caso de Narnia,
la experiencia que están teniendo
ahora, en el caso de Matrix
y así sucesivamente,
es una sombra de aquello que
realmente está más allá.
De hecho, este tema es central
en casi todas las
tradiciones religiosas.
El dominio de los laicos, de lo mundano,
de lo terrenal, es de
cierta manera irreal,
porque también existe un
dominio del más allá
y la interacción con él
proporciona un tipo de bien
que es infinitamente mejor que
los bienes derivados
de la interacción con este mundo, es
casi imposible compararlos.
Cuando Sócrates dice
que una persona con un
alma bien ordenada
pasa su tiempo contemplando las formas,
está haciendo exactamente el
mismo de tipo de afirmación
que un cristiano haría cuando dice
que al renunciar a los bienes terrenales
y enfocarse en lo que es
valioso espiritualmente,
uno gana un tipo de posibilidad para
prosperar que es incomparable
con aquello que se puede obtener
en el dominio terrenal.
El segundo argumento sobre la felicidad
afirma que la persona con el
alma bien ordenada
no solo ha experimentado
todos los placeres
y ha sentido subjetivamente
que este es el mejor,
sino que además tiene la razón.
Que el mayor de los placeres
viene del alma bien ordenada
que pasa su tiempo interactuando no
con lo mundano y lo terrenal,
sino con las ideas del más allá.
Una última cita.
Una de las maneras de hacer nuestro
el argumento de Sócrates
es mediante unas imágenes muy vivas.
Encontraremos de principio a fin, en
todos los autores que leamos,
que están intentando hacer argumentos
que apelan a las distintas
partes de nuestras almas.
Acabo de darles un montón de
argumentos que pasan por la razón
y ahora vamos a obtener una imagen
que supuestamente fijará
en sus mentes la idea que
Platón acaba de argumentar.
El pasaje dice así.
Lo leyeron de tarea para hoy.
"¿Una persona puede sacar
provecho de adquirir oro
de forma injusta si al hacerlo
esclaviza la mejor parte de sí mismo
a la más maliciosa?"
¿Entendido?
Es decir, la parte superior del muñeco
de nieve a la parte inferior.
Y aquí está la analogía.
"Si obtuvo el oro esclavizando
a sus descendientes
con el hombre malvado o salvaje,
no podrá beneficiarse,
sin importar cuánto oro
haya conseguido".
¿De acuerdo?
Si les dijera que pueden tener
todo el dinero del mundo
si venden a su hermano o
hermana como esclavos,
supongo que el sacrificio no sería
atractivo para la mayoría
y para quienes sí lo
consideren atractivo
recomiendo unos cursos de
relaciones humanas
que hay en el departamento
de psicología.
"No podrá beneficiarse,
sin importar cuánto oro
haya conseguido.
¿Cómo podría evitar ser desdichado
si esclaviza sin piedad la parte
más divina de sí mismo
a la parte más corrompida?".
La idea es la siguiente:
Cuando robas, cuando matas,
cuando permites que la parte
inferior de tu alma te haga actuar
en contra de lo que dice
tu parte superior,
entonces, eres igual que la persona
que tiene estas ganancias mal habidas.
Igual que vender a tus
descendientes como esclavos
no es una buena forma de hacer dinero,
tampoco lo es, dice Sócrates,
vender la parte superior de tu
alma a la esclavitud.
Sacrificarla a tus pasiones
y a tus apetitos.
Esta idea de que podemos tomar un
poco de la sabiduría popular
sobre la naturaleza de la felicidad,
pero reconociendo que solo capta
una parte de la verdad,
es una de las muchas cosas que suceden
en los pasajes de Jonathan Haidt
que les pedí leer para hoy.
Leímos 2 capítulos para hoy.
El capítulo 5 era obligatorio
y se trata de las teorías
contemporáneas de la felicidad.
El otro capítulo recomendado era el 7
y se trata de las virtudes.
Quiero hablar del capítulo 5, el
capítulo de la felicidad.
Acabamos de escuchar que Platón
dice, argumenta o sostiene,
a lo largo de este extenso libro,
que la prosperidad humana
no viene de la riqueza material ni
de los bienes físicos,
sino de algo que tal vez no se
les había ocurrido
que podía ser la fuente de la
prosperidad: la reflexión y la
sabiduría.
Los argumentos que brinda
usan los recursos de la tradición
a la que él pertenece.
Están ambientados en el
contexto de la antigua Grecia
y usan las herramientas de
argumentación de la filosofía.
De forma parecida, la discusión que
Jonathan Haidt proporciona
en el capítulo 5 intenta hacer
algo similar a Platón:
intenta demostrar que hay
un poco de verdad
en las ideas populares de lo que
significa la felicidad,
pero no han logrado obtener
un panorama completo.
Haidt lo hace, en parte,
usando la estrategia que les
describí anteriormente.
Toma la imagen de la idea popular,
proporciona un análisis más
profundo de ella y muestra que
en ambos casos se destacan más o
menos el mismo tipo de cosas.
Haidt, en especial en ese capítulo,
nos presenta 2 afirmaciones:
La primera es aquello que él llama
el principio del progreso.
El descubrimiento,
que parece contar con suficientes pruebas
conductuales y neurocientíficas
en la cultura estadounidense y en
otros contextos interculturales,
de que la mayor parte de nuestro
placer no viene de alcanzar
una meta, aunque una
parte viene de ahí,
sino del proceso para
alcanzar dicha meta.
La segunda idea,
que vuelve al material que
leímos la semana pasada
de Daniel Kahneman y al del día
anterior de Jonathan Evans,
es que debido a que somos más sensibles
a los cambios en los bienes que a los
niveles absolutos de bienes,
más de lo mismo no siempre
nos hace más felices.
Con más de lo mismo
tendemos a acostumbrarnos
y a desear un cambio
que significa tener incluso más de eso.
Para la siguiente diapositiva
necesito que saquen sus clickers,
así que prepárenlos.
No es algo muy interesante,
pero necesito que preparen sus clickers.
Esto da pie a algo que a veces se conoce
como la rutina hedónica.
La rutina hedónica es la idea
de que para mantener la misma
cantidad felicidad,
si está basada en bienes materiales,
tenemos que correr para
quedarnos en el mismo lugar.
Los principios psicológicos
sobre los que se basa
este principio de adaptación son
exactamente los mismos
que gobernaban los casos que
Kahneman describía.
Somos, como Kahneman demostró
en el sistema visual,
muy sensibles a los contrastes
y muy malos para hacer
juicios absolutos.
Volveremos a ese principio
cuando leamos el documento de Cass
Sunstein en la sección de ética.
Ok. La votación está
abierta y mi pregunta es:
¿Están listos para continuar?
Pulsen 1 si su respuesta es: "Sí, ya
quiero estudiar a Aristóteles"
Pulsen 2 si su respuesta es: "No, tengo
dudas sobre Platón o Haidt"
Ok. Esto es solo para
recuperar su atención
en caso de que los haya perdido
porque he estado parloteando demasiado.
Se supone que los clickers ayudan
a mantener su atención.
Ok. Tenemos... ¡ay, no!
Se supone que el reloj tenía que
empezar automáticamente.
Ya tenemos 118 votos.
Ok. Si eres...
¿Podemos saltar esto o no?
¡No! Eso fue peor.
Ok. No voy a tocarlo.
Si están en la categoría 2
y quieren hacer una pregunta
sobre Platón o Haidt,
háganla antes de que
descubramos qué tan raros son.
O tal vez, qué tan comunes.
Bien.
¿No hay preguntas?
Hay una pregunta.
Alumno: [inaudible]
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: No
entiendes el concepto de
"equivalente en extensión".
Sí.
Ok. Es un término filosófico.
Veamos qué tan raro eres y
después voy a...
Ok.
Aunque estás en el 9% voy a
responder a tu pregunta.
Se dice que 2 caracterizaciones son
equivalentes en extensión
si eligen el mismo conjunto
de cosas en el mundo.
Si yo digo: "Me interesa elegir
todas las figuras geométricas
que tengan 4 esquinas equidistantes".
Y tú dices: "Me interesa elegir
todas las figuras geométricas
que tengan 4 lados de la misma
longitud y 4 ángulos rectos".
Ambos estamos eligiendo los cuadrados,
aunque hayamos dado
distintas descripciones.
Si elijo a todos los
hermanos de sexo femenino
y tú eliges a todas las hermanas,
estamos eligiendo lo mismo aunque
usemos distintas descripciones.
Ok. Esto es una democracia.
Aunque Platón piensa que no es la
mejor forma de gobierno,
aquí lo haremos así.
Vamos a continuar.
Bien. Aristóteles.
Por lo menos, ya que tienen
clase de filosofía,
merecen que les explique esta imagen.
Esta imagen que ven en todos
los carteles del campus:
"¡Ven al centro de escritura!"
No sé por qué ponen a Platón y a
Aristóteles en el cartel de
"¡Ven al centro de escritura!",
pero será mejor que les diga
qué está pasando en esta imagen.
Es una pintura famosa
del gran pintor renacentista, Rafael.
Se llama La escuela de Atenas.
Muchos de los personajes dentro
de la pintura completa
representan a sus amigos.
Pueden ir a verla al Vaticano
si están interesados.
En el centro de la pintura,
como bien se sabe,
está Platón parado a la izquierda y
Aristóteles a la derecha.
Platón lleva en su mano, casi se alcanza
a leer, un libro llamado Timeo,
que es un libro de cosmología, y
está señalando hacia arriba,
algunos creen que porque está
señalando al reino de las formas.
Por el contrario, Aristóteles, lleva
en su mano el libro de Ética,
que es el libro que estamos leyendo.
Ética a Nicómaco, ahí está.
Tienen un libro que está en
la pared del Vaticano.
¡Qué emocionante!
Tienen la edición rústica de 6
USD, pero no importa.
Como sea, tienen ese libro.
La mano de Aristóteles está
aquí por 2 razones.
Ya sea porque está señalando
al dominio terrenal
como parte de su negación de la
imagen platónica de las formas
o porque está hablando de la
doctrina del medio,
de la que todos ustedes saben mucho
porque la leyeron para hoy.
Ok. La próxima vez que vean esta
imagen por lo menos sabrán
quiénes son estos 2 personajes:
Platón y Aristóteles.
Como saben, Aristóteles era
alumno de Platón.
El texto que leímos para
hoy es, a mi juicio,
uno de los trabajos más profundos
sobre psicología escrito
en los últimos 2500 años.
Sin embargo, es terriblemente
difícil de leer, en parte,
debido a que muchos de los diálogos
que escribió Aristóteles
se perdieron.
Y lo que tenemos aquí
son básicamente los apuntes de
clase de Aristóteles.
Verán que en una de las páginas dice:
"Ahora vamos a ver el gráfico".
¿Ok? Tenía una especie de
versión en papiro
de las diapositivas de PowerPoint.
No sé si estaban animadas
con imágenes que se mueven.
Pero lo que tenemos aquí
es una especie de apuntes un
poco difíciles de leer.
Como es mi libro favorito del
mundo, por muchas razones,
lo que vamos a hacer en la
siguiente diapositiva,
es que les voy a dar unas citas
y les voy a explicar qué
pasa en el texto.
Esta es la Ética de Aristóteles.
Si les expliqué a Platón
en 30 segundos,
esto lo haré en 60 más o menos.
Les explico lo que pasa:
El debate que leímos comienza al
principio del Libro I,
con un argumento que a veces se llama
el argumento a favor del summum bonum,
no necesitan anotarlo por eso no
lo puse en la diapositiva,
y otras veces se le dice
"el mayor bien".
Aquello que se persigue por sí mismo.
El argumento aquí es básicamente
algo que podríamos llamar
un argumento recíproco o dialelo.
Es como el argumento de valor
intrínseco o instrumental
que leímos en Platón.
La idea es que cada bien,
todo lo que buscamos,
lo perseguimos por sí mismo
o por algo más.
Si lo perseguimos por algo más,
debe echar por tierra algo
o sumarse a algo.
El summum bonum, el mayor bien:
debe complementar algo.
La pregunta a la que nos
enfrentamos cuando hacemos
lo que Aristóteles llama
ciencia política,
que no es lo mismo que hacen
en el departamento de
Ciencias políticas,
sino que es ciencia
política en el sentido
de que estudia a los humanos
como seres políticos,
es decir, como animales sociales.
El estudio de nosotros mismos como
criaturas arraigadas socialmente
es el estudio de cuál es el
mayor bien para los humanos.
Y el mayor bien para el ser
humano, dice Aristóteles,
tanto a juicio del hombre común,
es decir aquello que leerías en el
equivalente a los medios masivos
de la Grecia antigua, como a
juicio del hombre culto,
es la prosperidad o el eudemonismo,
a veces traducido como felicidad.
Eso es lo que todo mundo persigue.
Así comienzan los pasajes que
leímos del Libro I.
Ahí está la pregunta: ¿qué es lo
que persigue toda la gente?
La respuesta es: todos buscan lo mismo.
Buscan la felicidad, la
prosperidad, el eudemonismo.
La siguiente pregunta es:
¿Qué tipo de felicidad?
¿A qué nos referimos cuando nos
proponemos buscar la felicidad?
Aristóteles repasa una
serie de respuestas
que se han dado.
Verán que Aristóteles, como
buen alumno de Platón,
presenta una taxonomía
bastante conocida.
¿Son los placeres de la gratificación?
Es decir, los placeres
que Platón diría
que son los placeres del apetito.
"No", dice Aristóteles y
da sus razones.
¿Son los placeres del honor?
¿Lo que Platón llamaría los
placeres del ánimo o espíritu?
"No", dice Aristóteles y
da algunas razones.
¿Entonces, son los placeres
de la reflexión?
¿Las cosas que vienen de la razón?
"¡Sí!", dice Aristóteles.
Y ahora da algunas razones de esto.
Pero las razones que da
son distintas a las de Platón.
Porque Aristóteles rechaza la idea
de Platón de las formas.
Aristóteles no está mirando hacia
un dominio del más allá
para defender su visión.
Está mirando a un dominio interior
Son las 11:17.
Voy a explicar una diapositiva más
y terminaremos con Aristóteles
en la siguiente clase.
La pregunta es, si no puedes
recurrir a las formas
como tu justificación para la razón...
Recuerden que Platón tiene
esta explicación:
"¿Por qué la razón es tan buena?
Porque nos permite
conectarnos a un dominio
más allá de nosotros mismos".
Aristóteles no puede dar esa respuesta.
Entonces, ¿qué hace que la
razón sea tan buena?
Aquí está el argumento:
Cada objeto en el mundo,
tiene una función.
La función de un cuchillo
es cortar bien.
La función de un pisapapeles
es detener los papeles.
La función de un apuntador láser
es dirigir la atención a la
diapositiva, etc.
Una cosa buena
es aquella que funciona bien.
Su función la distingue de
otras entidades.
Los buenos pisapapeles son pesados,
los malos son ligeros o redondos
y se van rodando.
O invisibles y no los podemos encontrar.
O demasiado pesados para moverlos
y no los podemos levantar de
nuestros papeles.
Cuando algo tiene una función,
una buena versión de ese objeto
es evidente en sí misma
y le permite realizar su
función particularmente bien.
Entonces, ¿cuál es la
función de los humanos?
Para responder a esa pregunta,
tenemos que responder
qué tienen de especial
los seres humanos.
¿Qué nos distingue de las plantas
que absorben nutrientes?
¿Y de los animales que son
capaces de locomoción
y de tener sentimientos?
Lo que nos distingue de
ellos es la razón.
Al igual que los cuchillos son
buenos cuando cortan bien,
los humanos son buenos cuando
hacen esa cosa especial
de los seres humanos: cuando
usan bien la razón.
Escribió en 1098:
"La razón es la función
especial del ser humano".
Entonces, ¿cuál es el bien del humano?
El bien de un cuchillo es
ser evidentemente
lo más parecido a un cuchillo.
Por ejemplo, todas esas espadas mágicas
que hay en obras, películas y libros...
¿Qué hace que sean buenas espadas?
Que son especialmente capaces de
matar a los enemigos, ¿verdad?
Por eso las espadas son buenas espadas.
¿Qué hace que seas la espada de
Lancelot de los seres humanos?
Que tu alma está
estructurada de tal forma
que haces lo que es mejor, lo más
completo y distintivo de los humanos.
El buen ser humano es aquel
que hace mejor aquello
que hacen los humanos y resulta que
lo que hacen los humanos
es razonar y actuar según las virtudes.
La pregunta a la que volveremos al
inicio de la siguiente clase...
y todos pueden leer el desenlace,
de hecho, ya debieron
haberlo leído para hoy.
La pregunta es: ¿Cómo es la
virtud que nos hace perfecta
y magníficamente humanos?
¿Y cómo se cultiva?
Para el jueves tenemos que leer 3
cosas realmente estupendas.
Leeremos fragmentos de La Iliada,
les he dado 2 opciones.
Consulten la guía de lectura.
Pueden leer todo el Libro I
o pueden mirar el contexto de
cada uno de los pasajes
que Jonathan Shay nos da,
les puse las instrucciones
de cómo hacerlo.
Leeremos el maravilloso libro de
Jonathan Shay, Achilles in Vietnam,
y también leeremos el famoso "Estudio
conductual de la obediencia"
de Stanley Milgram de 1963.
Comenzaremos con Aristóteles
y después veremos los otros 3 textos.